thirty miles north of New York City
there's a small town haunted by the
legacy of the Headless Horseman 200
years after his first ride
I'm Jessica Hester staff writer at Atlas
obscura and this is how a fictional town
became reality
[Music]
when Washington Irving wrote The Legend
of Sleepy Hollow in 1820 the village
didn't exist though some of its
landmarks did like the old Dutch Church
he placed the story of Ichabod Crane the
schoolteacher and the beheaded hessian
soldier in north Tarrytown where the
church had been standing for centuries
[Music]
Sleepy Hollow was based on real
geography but it wasn't on the map
readers were spellbound by Irving's tale
of the Headless Horseman and soon fans
started showing up in North Tarrytown
but when the town's massive automotive
factory closed in 1996 and took
thousands of jobs with it the town put
its feature on the ballot and voted to
give itself a boost by rebranding a
Sleepy Hollow now you literally can't
turn a corner without running into the
horseman on a single block we saw him on
street signs on a police officers badge
on a permit tacked to a tree on a squad
car and on an ambulance that turned
right in front of it
he's even the mascot of the local high
school where the sign says home of the
horseman
fans sometimes get married in the Sleepy
Hollow cemetery on the bridges crossing
the Picanto co river where the horseman
is said to have banished this one isn't
the original experts aren't sure exactly
which one Irving was writing about but
it feels old and storied maybe because
it's so mossy and damp Washington Irving
is also buried inside the cemetery and
is on his third gravestone for years
fans chipped pieces of it off as
souvenirs Halloween is big business for
the horseman the gas station across the
street from the cemetery is stocked with
swag horsemen t-shirts travel mugs and
keychains are piled next to lighters and
allergy meds the loudest example of
horsemen tourism is the great
jack-o'-lantern blaze it's an Amir by
Town and it runs all season nearly
150,000 people wander around the grounds
of an old manor house leaving around
7,000 carved pumpkins
it's a giant spectacle complete with
choreographed lighting immersive special
effects even a creepy Original Score the
whole thing is very theatrical
but it's easy to get swept up in the
magic no matter how cynical you are
the Horseman's legacy is there - he's in
the gift shop and out in the yard where
a soundtrack plays a loop of clomping
hooves a whinny and a cackle it's not so
unusual for a town to rebrand itself but
few have gone bigger than Sleepy Hollow
here fact and fiction swirl together
centuries after it was written down the
legend still draws people to the place
that inspired the story and has now
claimed it as its own thanks so much for
watching subscribe to our channel to see
more awesome videos like this one and
hop into the comments and tell us about
your favorite local lore